on
non
les stations alpines sous haute
surveillance ce week-end les risques
d'avalanche sont importants
colas mitterrand ne confond donc pas
l'unification européenne et
réunification allemande
49 étudiants belges blessées lors d'une
explosion à la bombe
c'est le troisième attentat enregistrée
en 15 mois dans une université
bruxelloise petit excuse pour balestre
super licence pour senna c'est reparti
pour un tour
bonsoir le ciel serait-il devenu fou fou
on attendait désespérément la neige il
neige sur notre monde pour nos montagnes
mais pas pour notre plaisir on attendait
l'hiver on croit être au printemps mais
c'est désagréable les scientifiques eux
mêmes sont désorientés on ne comprend
plus et pour tenter de comprendre nous
avons invité laurent broomhead bonsoir
laurent avant de vous écouter faisons le
point sur une situation qui s'est
malheureusement aggravée dans quatre
régions - les alpes la bretagne l'alsace
et la franche-comté allons d'abord dans
les alpes où de nombreuses avalanches
risque encore de se produire tignes et
val d'isère est inaccessible et bourg
saint maurice a été transformé en qg
dalons maintenant regardez le reportage
de nos confrères de la station de
grenoble jérôme didier et berry sautel
toujours pas d'accalmie sur le front des
intempéries ans à bois où la situation
devient préoccupante
de nombreuses routes d'accès aux
stations ont été provisoirement fermée à
la circulation les risques d'avalanche
étant trop important ce le cas des
routes de belle plagne et dark 2000
mais c'est en haute tarentaise que la
situation est jugée ce soir critique par
les services de sécurité du département
tignes et val d'isère est inaccessible
et cela pourrait bien durer et des
risques encore d'avalanche juste en aval
du barrage et en l'état des choses étant
de la couverture et les nuages on n'est
pas capable de dire si les avalanches
sont descendues hoon
c'est pour ça que par mesure de
précaution la musique la route pour
l'instant est coupée look est depuis 48
heures à tignes ou à val d'isère les
touristes ont été autorisés cet après
midi à quitter les deux stations
olympiques mais sous la protection des
services de sécurité inutile de vous
dire que cette fuite en avant avait des
allures d'exode
c'est poser des questions on est parti
une journée plus tôt on se pose vraiment
des questions là où c'est quand même une
céda sous la neige tout le méditer
situation inquiétante par contre pour
les habitants du fort né au nord de val
d'isère coupé de tout contact depuis 72
500 personnes totalement isolées et sans
qu'il soit possible pour l'instant de
leur porter secours et de les
ravitailler en produits de première
urgence d'autres sont en revanche bloqué
mais à bourg-saint-maurice depuis 72
heures et on commence à s'impatienter
je suis arrivé mercredi soir et bien
d'autres qui mercredi
l'impossibilité de rejoindre tignes
j'attends alors j'étais avec ma mère
mais saha sont partis ce matin
moi j'ai décidé de rester lorsque vous
prends dans mes vacances je pense que sa
puce un peu plus tellement ça ira et les
trains en direction de la parenthèse ont
accusé aujourd'hui d'importants retards
mais pour la compagnie nationale les
véritables difficultés devraient débuter
demain 80 trains sont attendus durant
les prochaines 24 heures au départ et à
l'arrivée de bourg saint maurice où la
sncf vient de mettre en place des
centres d'hébergement cette situation
préoccupe le gouvernement il vous
demande de différer votre départ si vous
devez partir pour la montagne par
exemple en vacances il est donc
important d'avoir des informations
pratiques et précise sur ce qui se passe
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons nous rendre à lyon en direct au
centre routier pour rejoindre philippe
le maire philippe weppe hall autant le
dire tout de suite la situation reste
extrêmement difficile en montagne et
nous en sommes désolés pour tous les
vacanciers pourtant les services de
l'équipement ont travaillé toute la nuit
dernière et toute la journée pour
dégager les routes
mais l'accès à de nombreuses stations
surtout dans la vallée de la tarentaise
reste impossible
c'est le cas de val d'isère d'arc 2010
est lié toutes ces stations étant isolé
mais cela n'empêchera pas en principe
demain le premier ministre michel rocard
le visiter une ou deux stations pour se
rendre compte sur place de la situation
j'ajoute que pour prévenir les
conséquences dramatiques d'éventuels
avalanche le risque demeure le préfet de
savoie ont interdit ces tuiles accès aux
stations des menuires de val thorens ou
de saint françois longchamp
ailleurs ça passe à la reine mais avec
quelques précautions bon effectivement
comme vous l'avez souligné des
difficultés importantes d'un accès aux
stations de ski dont il est absolument
recommandé de partir en station avec ses
équipements
l'ensemble des stations de la région
rhône alpes les équipements sont
obligatoires ou nécessaire
d'autre part il faut préparer son voyage
c'est à dire se renseigner sur l'état
des routes avant d'effectuer son trajet
je suis renseigné jour sur ocre ivre 78
54 33 33 ou en consultant le minitel 36
15 route en ce qui concerne la situation
pour le week-end
de toute manière nous frayons même hors
circulation défavorables dus à des
conditions métier c'est la journée à
éviter d'une façon classique d'autant
plus demain merci à la à vous merci pour
ces informations pratiques après les à
valence les inondations tout aussi
catastrophique 3 région étaient
particulièrement touchés
la bretagne l'alsace et la franche-comté
nos stations elles mêmes en quelques
fois les pieds dans l'eau le point avec
morad aït habbouche l'eau le bruit de
l'eau omniprésent météo déréglé et
capricieuse ce matin le réveil a été
difficile pour une grande partie de la
france mais particulièrement dans le
doubs la preuve après avoir tourné ces
images notre station de besançon a dû
être évacuée situation grave voire
critique dans le département où le
fleuve a atteint sa cote d' alerte 7
mètres 70 niveaux historiques déjà cette
nuit les routes étaient transformées en
rivières seul moyen de locomotion la
barque partout l'armée les pompiers ont
été mobilisés dans la région de
baume-les-dames des milliers d'habitants
pris au piège ont dû être évacuées vers
des locaux aménagés à la hâte par les
mairies par endroits un signe optimiste
un décrue commence mais plus loin à
epinal le pessimisme est de rigueur la
moselle a là aussi atteint des niveaux
record on n'avait pas vu ça depuis un
demi siècle est rarement vu autant de
one
on connaît en connaissez ce baume
inondables enfin à ce niveau là excepté
le midi et le centre de la france
aucune région n'a été épargné par le
mauvais temps meurtrier parfois dans le
bas rhin un enfant d'une dizaine
d'années on vient de l'apprendre est
tombé dans une rivière il a été importé
disparition qui porte à huit le nombre
de victimes dans l'est de la france
bilan provisoire qui en bretagne la
situation est maintenant stable les
clous ont également été violente et les
glissements de terrain spectaculaire
comme ici à morlaix enfin conséquence
inattendue de ces pluies torrentielles
des usines submergées par l'eau ont dû
fermer leurs portes
ironie du sort cette entreprise de cahan
dans l'orne spécialisé dans les bottes
en caoutchouc ne peut plus travailler
chômage technique bien laurent broomhead
on a envie de comprendre on dit que le
ciel se déchaîne parce que la terre se
réchauffe est ce que c'est vrai écoutez
j'ai l'impression dans tout ça une
grande confusion
on confond le court terme et le long
terme on confond ce qui arrive dans
notre petit pays voir leur l'europe à ce
qui arrive à toute la planète on confond
en fait la météo et la climatologie la
météo qu'est ce que c'est c'est voir ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui quelques jours
et tenter de comprendre ce qu'il se
passera dans quelques heures quelques
jours quinze jours ou plus ça ne donne
pas le temps qu'il fera dans un an
autrement dit c'est pas parce que nous
avons un univers très chaud d'ailleurs
trois de suite plutôt chaud que le
prochain ne sera pas complètement glace
et ça c'est un premier problème est
alors quand on fait des statistiques sur
un siècle une cham usa avec cet après
midi avec la météo nationale on voit
qu'il ya pas de grandes évolutions
depuis un siècle
même sur la neige par exemple audi a
moin en moin neige c'est pas vrai j'ai
vu les statistiques la courbe en savoie
à 12 100 m c'est pas vrai ça va c'est
vrai c'est très variable entre 0 et 130
cm mais d'une manière aléatoire on a
l'impression que les nuages l'atmosphère
joue aux dés et jouent un peu avec nos
nerfs le climat c'est autre chose
le climat c'est ça c'est toute la
planète est là pour bouger l'atmosphère
de toute la planète ça prend non pas des
mois mais des années voire des siècles
alors c'est vrai qu'il faut se
préoccuper c'est humainement capitale de
ce qui se passe avec le gaz carbonique
de ce qui se passe avec la couche
d'ozone mais c'est pas là dedans dans
ces études là même s'il ya des risques
même s'il faut les étudier qu'on doit
chercher les raisons des intempéries on
retrouve votre passion mais l'homme est
peut-être aussi en partie responsable
même brice lalonde le reconnaît
implicitement mais si vous est ce que je
trouve un petit peu c'est que d'abord il
est responsable de pas comprendre tout
ça parce qu'on ne la prend pas à l'école
on nous explique pas ce que c'est que
les statistiques les probabilités jardy
moyenne
on vit à court terme et ça qu'on peut
pas reprocher au public cela il a la
mémoire courte
on peut reprocher aux scientifiques
parfois de profiter de cette confusion
générale pour tirer la couverture à eux
essayé d'en profiter
et je pense que autant ils doivent
négocier pour avoir des budgets
suffisants recherche scientifique sur
l'atmosphère autant ils doivent pas
intensifier la profession du grand
public donc je retiens le maître mot
humilité
oui puis peut-être environnement
économique on découvre à cette occasion
qu' on vit beaucoup trop à court terme
et que la planète
elle est là le temps des milliers
d'années devant elle merci laurent
broomhead l'horreur dans un amphithéâtre
de bruxelles en belgique une centaine
d'étudiants écouter tranquillement leurs
profs quand une explosion s'est produite
dans la salle même la plupart d'entre
eux sont à l'hôpital et se demande
encore qui a bien pu commettre une telle
folie parce qu'il s'agit bel et bien
d'un attentat clément weill raynal qui
peut bien en vouloir aux universités
belges c'est la troisième fois en 15
mois qu'une faculté bruxellois est visé
par un attentat à l'explosif attentats
jusqu'à présent jamais revendiqué une
quarantaine de blessés dont 13
grièvement brûlé l'attentât de ce matin
à la faculté de louvain est de loin le
plus grave de la série il était 9h ce
matin lorsque la bombe incendiaire très
violente a explosé dans un amphithéâtre
où une centaine d'étudiants assistait à
un cours de pharmacie
et à sortir dans les vêtements flamber
l'une d'entre elles était très
vilainement brûlé au visage et aux
extrémités quand je soupçonne qu'elle
lui avoir des flammes très importante
n'avait jamais eu aucune menace
personnellement jamais non
ni à l'université ni moi même
selon les premiers indices recueillis la
bombe était dissimulée dans un
attaché-case cette bombe contenait un
savon liquide explosif dont l'effet est
comparable à celui du napalm
la police a également relevé des
similitudes avec un attentat à la bombe
commis en décembre dernier dans une
autre université de bruxelles
pardon pour ce journal plutôt triste
pour ce début de journal mais
l'actualité est ainsi fait un accident
s'est produit en suisse en garde de
saxon le milan paris a heurté un convoi
d'entretien le bilan est de trois morts
et douze blessés laurence piquet un choc
particulièrement violent
vers 1h30 ce matin l'express y recule à
120 kilomètres/heure lorsqu'il percute
en convoi d'entretien à proximité de la
gare de 500 près de lausen la locomotive
de l'express écrase 200 mètres plus loin
si wagon des rails le conducteur de
l'express et deux cheminots du convoi de
maintenance sont tués horrible tout le
monde criait et criait et je tournais
comme comme une boule sait plus ce qu'il
fallait faire tout le monde saute et
sortez parfait après tout le monde
hurlait 12 passagers blessés dont deux
grièvement
à l'origine de cet accident une erreur
humaine selon les premières
constatations
une enquête a été ouverte elle devra
expliquer la présence d'un convoi de
services sur ces voies principales
furent en afrique du sud
un espoir de solution politique la haine
c'est le mouvement nationaliste fait un
pas vers le pouvoir blanc lines et se
dit prête à rencontrer le président de
clerck grâce sans doute aux bons
conseils de nelson mandela hiver
couturier réunis à l'usa qu'un la
direction de la haine c'est donc prêt à
ouvrir des négociations sur les
négociations car les mesures annoncées
par le président de clercq est selon
elle un complète manque la levée de
l'état d'urgence la libération de tous
les prisonniers politiques et le retrait
de l'armée des tall ship la position
modérée adoptée par nelson mandela
favorable au compromis semble cependant
faire école bien qu'il soit toujours
partisan du maintien de la lutte armée
et des sanctions
des sanctions qui ne devrait pas
s'aggraver mais dont les états unis
attendent pour l'élever la
concrétisation des réformes engagées par
le gouvernement sud-africain des
sanctions qui coûte cher à l'économie du
pays en favorisant le désinvestissement
des sociétés étrangères principalement
américaines
recevant les ambassadeurs d'une
vingtaine de pays nelson mandela leur a
d'ailleurs demandé d'accroître leur
pression sur pretoria afin d'accélérer
le changement reste que l'ouverture
prochaine de bureaux de l'insee en
afrique du sud risque de faire bondir
les conservateurs et l'extrême droite
qui manifestaient hier à pretoria des
provocations paraissent donc inévitable
pour tenter de freiner le processus
politique qui va s'engager un sommet
exceptionnel réunira en avril à dublin
les douze dirigeants européens l'objet
de ce sommet la question allemande qui
passionne les citoyens des deux
allemagne mais qui préoccupent les
citoyens des autres pays européens
il se demande si l'allemagne réunifiée
si la grande allemagne ne va pas tenter
de dominer politiquement le vieux
continent
c'est ce qui a inspiré aujourd'hui bape
prenant le temps de découvrir son dessin
il faut dire qu'un tel écueil a été
évité jusqu'à présent grâce à l' axe
franco allemand
mais cette taxe est il encore aussi
solide la réponse de mémona hintermann
mitterrand et kohl s'appelle par leur
prénom
jusqu'à ce que cole annonce son plan en
dix points pour l'unité allemande en
novembre
les relations entre les deux hommes
était particulièrement confiants depuis
la trop lente pression que l'autre la
forme de ses intentions coup par coup
les consultations ne sont plus vraiment
ce qu'elle était l'axé franco allemand
mise en place par de gaulle et adenauer
avait déjà connu des désagréments du
temps de george pompidou et de vibrantes
mais jamais l'entente entre les deux
pays n'avaient été soumise à autant
d'incertitudes
question quel est l'avenir pour cet axe
franco allemand il a déjà éclaté fax
franco-allemand est mort le 9 novembre à
berlin pour une raison très simple
l'allemagne est redevenue ce jour l'an
son principal centre d'intérêt à
elle-même et elle gardera de saines
relations d'amitié avec nous mais pas
davantage n'a plus besoin de nous
l'europe communautaire c'est un enfant
du rideau de fer
on voulait bâtir un super état pour se
défendre des russes à l'ombre du rideau
de fer
dès lors qu'à plus de rideau de fer
qu'on a plus peur des russes chacun
retrouve sa place dans l'histoire et les
plus optimistes nuance ce point de vue
mais chacun reconnaît une nouveau c'est
la france doit imaginer une riposte pour
contrebalancer le poids politique de
l'alma
nous sommes plus en 1914 une allemagne
dominatrice sur le plan militaire paraît
improbable
mais la force de son économie a ajouté à
ses intérêts politiques risque d'être un
vrai défi pour l'amitié
une information qui va intéresser tous
les enseignants qui regardent le 19/20 à
vence dans les alpes-maritimes
c'est malheureusement la fin de l'école
freinet qui a innové dans toutes les
méthodes de pédagogique la fille du
célèbre pédagogue des années 30 baisse
les bras
impossible de continuer à entretenir les
locaux assez vétustes de cette école
privée qui n'a pas d'aidé extérieure le
reportage d'anne gouro et de christophe
airaud 1935 célestin freinet instituteur
bâti sa propre école sur une colline de
vence au coeur de 14 mille mètres carrés
de forêts et de broussailles 1990 même
bâtiment même pédagogie mais cette fois
l'école freinet met la clé sous la porte
l'argent et non le temps aura eu raison
de celui qui reste soixante ans après le
précurseur de l'enseignement moderne on
retrouve la pensée non seulement la
pensée mais les méthodes mais jusqu aux
phrases clés de leur père dans tout dans
toutes les directives du ministre de
l'éducation nationale il faudrait au
moins que l'état rende à freiner ce qui
lui appartient l'interné et j'ai compris
il m'a dit les quelques mots qu'il
fallait pour mercer acceptant seulement
ici pas d'estrade ni de cours magistral
les 63 élèves travaillent seuls à le
rythme c'est à l'enseignante de faire la
navette entre les enfants et de les
pousser à la créativité
une démarche que peu d'écoles primaires
se donne les moyens et le temps
d'appliquer
malgré l'évolution de l'éducation
nationale de semaine et quand est-ce que
tu décides des limites que tu va fixer
son ton plein copie ci devenue peu à peu
musée vivant l'école accueille des
milliers de visiteurs chaque année comme
cet instituteur en vacances et visiteurs
pour qui la fermeture de l'école
impliquerait la fin d'un symbole
pédagogique qu'elle me dit qu'il faut
que j'aie qu'il faut défendre mais c'est
plus calme est une réalité qui vit bien
et qui travaille bien moi je
c'est pour ça que je venu pour pour
connaître sa vraie malgré les frais de
scolarité de 1150 francs par mois malgré
l'aide de l'état qui prend en charge le
salaire des trois institutrices l'école
ne rouvrira pas en septembre 90 à moins
que à moins qu'un mécène finances ce
symbole en péril ou que l'état prenne le
relais en rachetant le domaine le
ministère a chargé un inspecteur général
d'étudier le dossier sur place
l'occasion peut-être pour l'éducation
nationale de payer sa dette morale
envers célestin freinet
les amateurs de formule 1 donc vont être
rassurés ce soir on assistera l'année
prochaine un beau duel entre alain prost
et ayrton senna senna participera cet
officiel ce soir à ce championnat du
monde décision prise à la suite d'un
autre duel qui a opposé sénat à balestre
c'est assez incompréhensible
mais alain leblond bateau nous expliquer
le privé pilotes ne seront pas inscrits
ce soir à minuit dans les conditions
réglementaires
le pourront pas disputer le championnat
du monde en posant cet ultimatum le
président de la fifa demandait
clairement une lettre d'excusés à ayrton
senna
seule condition pour l'attribution de sa
superlicence 15h05 aujourd'hui un
communiqué indique la liste des 35
pilotes engagés dans le championnat du
monde de f1
coup de théâtre le nom de senna
n'apparaît pas il est remplacé dans
l'écurie mclaren par celui de l'anglais
john alton palmer sénat n'a donc pas
d'effectuer cette excuse la veille
16h15 nouveau communiqué indiquant que
la fédération accorde la super licence à
senna que s'est-il passé entre-temps le
président valette vient juste de
déclarer qu'il a bien reçu une lettre d'
excuses de senna hier mais que le
véritable revirement de l'afer a été
provoquée par un coup de téléphone du
brésilien se disant prêt à accepter
toutes les exigences de la fisam c'est
clair ou presque en moins d'une heure
tout est rentré dans l'ordre
comme par magie et le champion du monde
88 réintègre donc son écurie fétiche
mais la fin de l'histoire ne dit pas
pour l'instant que devient la fortune
est jonathan palmer un match déterminant
de main pour le quinze de france qui
affronte l'ecosse déterminant parce que
le quinze de france a été vous le savez
humilié par l'angleterre c'est la raison
pour laquelle il ya eu des changements
importants au sein de l'équipe qui va
demain affronter l'ecosse me découvrez
sur votre écran les six changements qui
se sont produits et ces changements
actrice tu notre spécialiste du rugby
alain dorgans qui ne voit dans cette
équipe aucun joueur de toulouse et de
toulon les deux équipes phares du
championnat de france de rugby et il
nous dit pourquoi cette composition là
ne lui plaît guère indolence toulon
toulouse les deux clubs phare du rugby
français depuis cinq ans paradoxe ils
sont mis au ban de la fédération demain
pour ikos france pas un seul toulousain
pas un seul toulonnais n'est retenu
l'imaginé michel platini composer
l'équipe de france sans les joueurs de
bordeaux et de marseille
dans le cas qui occupent toulon
l'entraîneur daniel herrero est
contestée par le giron fédéral
son franc-parler sa pédagogie du rugby
et ses convictions politiques diffèrent
de celles des instances dirigeantes
résultat le clad est banni voyez
toujours un peu pénible savoir que vos
opinions
parce qu'elle sent simplement
différentes sont mal apprécié ou perçus
comme les et des options ennemis bon si
c'est le cas de notre génération ça me
ça me ferait de la peine quoi mais c'est
vrai que nous pensons que certains de
nos joueurs à un moment ont souffert
peut-être d'être de toulon où la liberté
de parole des héros n'est pas forcément
toujours précises prenez jérôme bianchi
son seul titre de gloire celui de
champion de france acquis par son club
aux dépens du racing
hormis ces deux sélections en équipe de
france son palmarès reste quelconque
et pourtant l'arrière toulonnais et de
l'étop des meilleurs passent aux
solutions de de vouloir un jour joue en
équipe de france cécile de s'affirmer
quoi faut-il remanier l'équipe de france
ou procéder à une chirurgie au sein de
l'appareil fédéral une vision
allégorique de daniel herrero semble
qu'aujourd'hui on voit on voit souffler
le vent un peu de partout quoi sur le
plan politique on le voit alès on le
voit à l'ouest on le voit aujourd'hui en
afrique du sud
il semble que des gens qui peuvent pas
parler un joueur ne peut plus et eagle
comme il ya le fort quoi bon la tempête
souffle de partout je pense qu'à court
terme elle peut abattre les plus solides
des roquois et peut-être il ya quelques
uns d'entre eux fédération qui pourrait
bien se décider
les temps changent les new yorkais ont
fêté hier en grande pompe un
anniversaire au hard rock café
il s'agit d'une créature qui a eu droit
à tous les honneurs il
il ya droit tous les jours tous les
honneurs mais qu'ils étaient écartés
dans les années 40 ou 50 elle était trop
sexy
michel vial elle vieillit plutôt bien
notre betty boop international depuis 60
ans qu'elle balance sans retenue ni
embarras une croupe plus caisse précise
depuis 60 ans et les débuts du cinéma
parlant quête blues des coquinerie
acidulées de sa petite bouche de gros à
égorger de soleil fait des ravages notre
starlette flux est prise aux tentes
véritable bombe sexuelle miniatures des
petits écrans de notre enfance
à ce titre elle a même eu à subir les
foudres de la censure à force d'avoir
incarné les minettes affriolantes qui
excite les vieux messieurs gaillard tout
en câlinant les bébés et des petits
chiens
une ambiguïté aussi sulfureuse que
malicieuse qui ne pouvaient qu'irriter
la prude amérique des années 50 de
soufre 7 évaporée depuis longtemps et la
télévision ne renvoie plus aujourd'hui
que la malice et l'impertinence de vertu
qui perpétue la jeunesse de betty boop
et celle de cap calloway qui lui
rendaient hommage hier soir à new york
ce journal est terminée dans quelques
instants michel tour et vous donnera
toutes les informations sur le temps
qu'il sera ce soir et demain écouter le
attentivement parce que la situation
s'est malheureusement aggravée un
dernier bilan vient d'être publiée par
la sécurité civile il y a eu 14 morts et
deux disparus 14 morts et deux disparus
depuis mercredi
et je vous donne le numéro que vous
devez appeler si vous avez l'intention
de partir en vacances ou de partir pour
la montagne 48 94 33 33 je vous laisse
le temps de noter ce numéro 48 94 33 33
marques hautement vous donnera bien sûr
d'autres informations à 22h15 ce soir au
cours du journal soir 3 après thalassa
et après la classe
bonsoir à lundi les journaux du week-end
où seront présentées par eric achats
bonsoir
doublement